And when I come here to Australia, yeah,...
...when I look around and I see the landscape...
...but it does feel very similar to Canada.
The trees: it's really clean, it's really pretty.
I think the people are really nice here and people are really friendly in Canada.
It's really nice to be back in Australia.
I haven't been here for a good few years...
...so, I'm happy to be here.
I went surfing yesterday.
I landed literally at like six in the morning...
And was that a couple of hours?
I went to the zoo and I've never surfed here before...
It's something that I've just taken up finally.
I couldn't believe it. I actually went to Manly beach and I did it and...
...it was a lot of fun.
And I love it, it's cool and I'm...
...really happy to be able to say now officially I've surfed in Australia.
I think that my line is really just...
...for chicks who like to express themselves through fashion and...
...my line is about...
...it's kind of rock and roll and it's bold and...
...I'd want anyone to wear it, anyone who enjoys it, I hope people like it.
I love it, I design it for me and...
...today, I'm wearing an Abbey Dawn t-shirt but I...
...ripped it up and put a bunch of safety pins in it and...
...had fun with it and that's what the line is all about.